[Musique]
on est ravis d'accueillir notre invité
pour chantal non j'aurais tous ou sept
merci d'être là vous êtes vous êtes
documentaliste au lycée carcouët pagnol
de meudon et vous venez nous parler de
la littérature sur l'accouchement
domicile rabanne ou demain ce sera
pareil ça m'arrange où l'info jadis on
cherche à se rafraîchir un peu plus ce
sera plus bas ça va être intéressant et
servez très frais qu amour c'est très
clair je pense qu'après le générique ça
ira mieux générique bonne année oui bon
allez de vive voix tous les deux ça fait
plaisir de vous retrouver l'être les
musiques et les niveaux réunis vous
payons de soleil alors attention à leur
temps juste après s'il me plaît pas à
prendre avec vous que le virus aurait
également un impact sur les fonctions
sexuelles
oui à vrai dire au début de la pandémie
personne ne s'est intéressé à cette
question et c'est parfaitement normal
face à une infection qui est
potentiellement grave mortel mais depuis
quelques mois on commence à voir des
études scientifiques qui montrent que
quand on a une inflexion quand on avait
russe on peut développer des troubles
sexuels que l'infection soit bénigne ou
sévères d'ailleurs et c'est des troubles
sexuels qui peuvent persister dans le
temps en particulier des troupes de
libido chez la femme ou chez l'homme et
des troubles de l'érection
mais vingt plus grosses masses aussi
cette rue ok si ma saucisse te fait rien
alors je suis comblé on sent que le
couple s'est remis à this way et merci
pour ta discrétion
les experts pensent de plus en plus que
ces médicaments de l'érection pourrait
être utile contre lacko vide je sais que
ça ressemble à une blague de dire qu'on
me donne les médicaments de l'érection
pour améliorer la maladie qu vide mais
c'est une donnée scientifique validée
qui vient d'être publié dans des revues
médicales internationales dépasser les
2000 vaccination hier c'est à dire x 50
par rapport à la semaine dernière
aujourd'hui on va augmenter d'ici jeudi
on va augmenter encore de façon très
importante
on va être sur une courbe exponentielle
rassurez-vous par rapport à cela c'est à
dire que la situation le rythme de
croisière de la vaccination en france va
rejoindre celui de nos voisins dans les
prochains jours vous parlez contre vous
allez maintenant la wii allait
maintenant qu on va le faire mais je
suis obligé de les séparer
c'est comme à l'école avec l'enfer mais
à banon permettait pas voilà moi je suis
vous cette année profiter ça machin
c'est quoi cette prime ses 30 ans nicki
minaj et la science donald
un duo c'est pas vrai tu as voté pour
lui ouais c'était une grosse erreur
tu t'es carrément foire et ouais en fait
je travaillais à new york et un de mes
collègues nous a proposé à une amie et
moi d'aller passer un week end chez ses
parents à pittsburgh en pennsylvanie
hockey et on his nous y sommes allés en
arrivant il nous dit demain il sait la
journée associative à laquelle
appartient mes parents donc si vous
voulez venir nous y sommes allés il ya
eu un grand barbecue est le parrain 2
l'association était chuck norris à
bastia ces gars je vous souhaite une
bonne année
ce n'est pas une blague c'est bien chuck
norris l'acteur américain de walker
texas ranger qui présente ses voeux aux
causes est approuvée par toutes leurs
services proposés par un site américain
qui s'appelle caméo et qui vous propose
des dédicaces de stars personnalisé 1
328 euros pour 30 secondes de chuck
norris mais le tarif varie selon la star
que vous choisissez épuisant ils ont
organisé un tournoi de lancer de fer à
cheval
ben évidemment donc j'ai découvert cette
pratique et ils ont fait un tirage au
sort et je suis tombé en binôme avec lui
et donc j'ai joué j'ai passé
l'après-midi à ses côtés
franchement c'est la classe c'est pas
mal mais tout le monde est en charente
maritime ne peut pas dire j'ai fait un
tournoi de lancer de fer à cheval avec
chuck norris ça on est dans un cadre où
locks le message publié sur les réseaux
sociaux amusé les internautes certains
disent que ses voeux les ont davantage
réconforter que ceux du président
d'autres qu'il faudrait un vaccin à base
d'une souche de chuck norris ça existe
aussi en france
j'ai découvert cette nuit le site vide
au léo qui propose des dédicaces vidéo
personnalisée contée par exemple 40
euros pour une vidéo de francky vincent
l'histoire de thomas dowd c'est celle
d'un réveillon de noël un peu trop
arrosée passée devant la télé à regarder
un concert de son idole ce soir-là il a
rempli un formulaire en ligne débourser
une centaine d'euros pour changer de nom
ça il l'avait totalement oublié jusqu'à
recevoir quelques jours plus tard ses
papiers à signer pour officialiser sa
demande cette fois thomas 7 est sobre
mais il a décidé d'aller au bout de sa
démarche et de s'appeler pour de vrai
mister céline dion c'est vraiment mon
look préféré sur toi comptant sur le
soutien
ce que cette empathie naturelle ce que
tu as pour moi c'est incroyable
s'il ya bien une personne dans le monde
qui peuvent soutenir dans ces moments
difficiles je sais que c'est toi je
serai derrière parce que je vais
peut-être pas échappé olala c'est bon
c'est bon là je nous montre comment ça
défile une miss mais demi ça use ça
défile avec beaucoup d'assurance
surtout un grand smile tout faire ça au
second degré
et alors qu'est ce qu'a fait pas la fête
du nom mais elle me clash on me doit
pieds n'importe quoi enfin j'ai trouvé
ça tellement débile ferme en laissant
des films avant je le fais par an ah ben
tu devrais pas ce que c'est vraiment
moins cher ma belle
je crois que le vernis tu l'a oublié je
sais pas où tu l'as laissé m'étais vers
de terre sont en train de s'échapper et
vraiment c'est pas beau à voir
je passe un an vilaine vilaine oui on
valide
santoro